okay it is time for hatred mail I'm
going to first introduce what hatred
mail is and then I do have we have a
problem with hatred mail that I'm going
to tell you about in a second okay but
just as a reminder this is what hatred
mail is because it's God's divine plan
that every child be born but an act of
patriotic duty to snuff that bastard if
he sets a foot near your stuff Patriot
Man written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay so before we get to this
week's hey treat male hatred mail has
been been growing in popularity and I'm
now regularly getting emails from people
saying David you should do hatred mail
every single day I love it I just put
the hatred mail playlist on repeat and
listen to it all day that's the idea I
can't do it every day because I need
people wanting more of it or it becomes
boring and old and played out so the
fact that so many people want more of it
means that we're doing exactly the right
thing so we I don't want to dilute the
power of hatred mail and that's why we
are not increasing the frequency of
hatred mail but we do still have hatred
mail today let's take a listen to this
one
Pakman a liberal loon who is
regurgitator of fake news probably Don
Lemon boy friend put that whiny little
pac-man pee in his place hey doesn't
David Pakman identify as Jewish what is
with these Jews not acknowledging that
it's the Torah that calls for these type
of sodomite type of men to be put to
death
Pakman is revealing his snowflake status
have I ever suggested that I care about
what the Torah says about anything
this idea that if the Torah says it then
I should be following I don't know what
anyone could ever have seen on the David
Pakman show to suggest that and it's a
common theme we've patriotism is
actually up big over the last three
months I would say more than we've ever
even seen partially because the show's
audience continues to grow and is bigger
than ever so simple math implies that
there would be
or hatreds but the level of crazy and
how unhinged some of these are has
definitely grown we the I don't talk
about this often but we actually don't
publish lots of would be hatred mail
because it's so crazy that I have to
turn it over to law enforcement and I
hate that that's the reality that that's
the the world we live in but there's a
whole other level of hatred mail that
you will never hear because it's turned
over to the authorities as potentially
threatening and and potentially credible
threats remember you can turn hatred
mail into something positive the coupon
code hey tree at forty saves you forty
percent off of membership at david
pakman.com slash membership